[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir un contingent kenyan dans
l'est de la République démocratique du
Congo après d'un millier de soldats vont
être déployés progressivement pour
lutter contre le M23 un déploiement qui
intervient plusieurs mois après
l'annonce de la mise en place d'un d'une
force régionale par la Communauté des
États d'Afrique de l'Est nous serons un
aérobie dans ce journal
cette annonce de cessation d'hostilité
entre le gouvernement éthiopien et les
rebelles du Tigré un accord sous l'égide
de l'ONU l'Union africaine a pretori en
Afrique du Sud il intervient après deux
ans de conflit les détails dans un
instant et puis la condamnation de l'ex
commandant rebelle libérien Kunti Camara
par la cour d'assises de Paris il a
écopé de la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour des actes de barbarie
commis pendant la première guerre civile
au Liberia
on commence donc par ces images du
président kenyan William routeau qui
remet le drapeau du pays au contingent
qui va combattre dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo une
cérémonie qui marque le lancement
officiel de la mission ces hommes vont
servir au sein de la Force régionale est
africaine déployée pour lutter contre
les groupes armés dans les deux qui vous
dans leur ligne de mire les rebelles du
M23 la correspondance anaérobie de
Bastien renouy
il s'agit d'une mission pour protéger
l'humanité ce sont les mots graves du
président kenyan William auto des propos
tenus devant les troupes kenyan qui vont
être envoyés dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo il s'agit d'une
mission extrêmement importante il était
urgent que la Communauté Est Africaine
réagisse pour protéger la région contre
les criminels contre les terroristes et
contre les groupes armés ce sont les
mots du président kenyan on ne sait peu
de choses à propos des troupes qui vont
être déployés sur place il y avait
plusieurs centaines de soldats présents
à la cérémonie ce mercredi matin mais le
gouvernement Kenyon refuse de dire
combien seront réellement déployés sur
le terrain et c'est officiellement pour
des raisons de sécurité ce que l'on sait
c'est qu'ils devront traverser l'Ouganda
pour se rendre dans la ville congolaise
de bounagana à la frontière avec
l'Ouganda une ville qui est aux mains du
M23 actuellement il y a d'ailleurs déjà
près de 200 soldats Kenyans selon nos
informations au niveau de cette
frontière qui ont préparé depuis des
semaines l'arrivée des troupes envoyées
ce jour depuis Nairobi combien de temps
vont-ils rester sur place impossible de
le dire pour l'instant ils ont un mandat
de 6 mois mais qui pourrait être
renouvelées si nécessaire en marge de
cette cérémonie le président Kenyans
s'est entretenu avec son homologue
burunday evaristeimier qui est
d'ailleurs le président en exercice de
la Communauté Est Africaine le président
burunday a parlé à tous ces homologues
de la région ce mercredi et ce pour
organiser une grande réunion entre chef
d'État et africain et chef des armées et
ce afin d'organiser la riposte contre
les groupes armés dans l'est de la
République démocratique du Congo
et en République démocratique du Congo
tout autre chose le procès de Jean-Marc
cabunt l'ancien vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale et ancien proche
collaborateur de Félix Tshisekedi il
restera à la prison de Makala pendant
toute la durée de son procès c'est ce
qui a déclaré la Cour de cassation de
Kinshasa ce mercredi il y est détenu
depuis le 12 août dernier coûté son
avocat
jusqu'aujourd'hui l'ordonnance
d'assignation à résidence surveillée qui
avait été prononcé depuis le 12 août
continue à souffrir d'exécution nous
sommes dans un état de droit et c'est
tout le monde qui le dit on nous chante
matin un soir que la République
démocratique du Congo est un État de
droit alors pour exécuter un acte très
facile très simple ça demande pas grand
chose parce que la résidence de Jean
macaboum c'est connu c'est à King abois
et tout le monde l'a dit et mais
pourquoi ne pas la signer à résidence
chez lui à la maison et pour lui
permettre également de poursuivre les
travaux parlementaires qui ont débuté
depuis le 15 septembre
voilà il répondait aux questions de
notre correspondante Aurélie bazarraki
bangoula ce Cécile feu entre le
gouvernement éthiopien et les rebelles
du Tigre et il a été signé sous l'égide
de l'Union africaine après Tori en
Afrique du Sud les belligérants se sont
accordés sur une trêve après deux ans de
conflit l'espoir d'une paix durable et
toutefois fragile d'autres Trèves
avaient été signés avant d'être violée
kalidoussi
le début d'une nouvelle ère pour
l'Éthiopie c'est par ces mots que
l'Union africaine s'est réjouit de
l'accord de cessation des hostilités
entre le gouvernement éthiopien et les
rebelles du Tigré
les deux parties au conflit éthiopien
ont formellement accepté la cessation
des hostilités ainsi que le désarmement
systématique structuré harmonieux et
coordonnées
[Musique]
un accord également salué par les
rebelles du tigre
en ce qui concerne les deux parties nous
avons fait des concessions douloureuses
car il est bien plus important de
répondre aux souffrances de notre peuple
que de faire des concessions oui nous
avons fait des concessions parce que
nous avons établi la confiance et nous
devons nous assurer que tout le monde
s'appuie rapidement sur cette confiance
le conflit a débuté en novembre 2020
quand les dirigeants d'un groupe rebelle
le front de libération du peuple du
Tigré critique le gouvernement qui tente
selon lui de centraliser le pouvoir il
reproche également un traité de paix
conclu par Addis-Abeba et le voisin
érythréen concernant un territoire
contesté en réponse en septembre 2020
les rebelles du Tigré organisent des
élections régionales un acte jugé
illégal par les autorités éthiopiennes
deux mois plus tard le premier ministre
Abi Ahmed accuse les rebelles d'attaques
contre les camps de l'armée et lancent
une offensive en mars 2022 un cessé le
feu est conclu mais cinq mois plus tard
les affrontements reprennent si le bilan
du conflit reste inconnu l'ONU estime
cette guerre responsable de près de 500
000 morts plus de 2 millions d'estopiens
ont été déplacés et des centaines de
milliers en proie à la famine
la cour d'assises de Paris a condamné
mercredi lex commandant rebelle County
Camara à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité pour des actes barbarie
pendant la première guerre civile au
Liberia et pour s'être rendu complice de
crimes contre l'humanité en facilitant
des viols à l'énoncé du verdict l'accusé
est resté impassible le verdict a été
rendu après 9 heures de délibérer
écouter l'avocat de Civitas maxima ONG
qui avait déposé une plainte contre l'ex
commandant rebelle
ça prouve aujourd'hui que même son
téléphone portable même dans un pays où
tout le monde a oublié les victimes le
Liberia la communauté internationale a
complètement oublié le Liberia et ben
c'est cette quête de justice de ses
victimes qui se sont organisées toutes
seules alors que dans leur pays il y a
des sénateurs qui sont des criminels de
guerre et qui sont encore au pouvoir
elles ont le courage d'aller chercher
justice qu'elle trouvait pas chez elle
et on a eu un procès en verdict en
Suisse l'année passée aujourd'hui on en
a ici et ça je pense que ça donne
énormément d'espoir assez victimes
libériennes je pense que leur soif et
leur quête de justice a été reconnu et
ça évidemment pour nous c'est ce qu'on
cherchait et je pense que ce sera ce
sera important pour elle
jours pour jour après l'assassinat de
nos confrères Ghislaine Dupont et Claude
Verlon à Kidal dans le nord du Mali la
bourse portant leur nom a été remise à
Dakar au Sénégal ce jeudi cette bourse
récompense une journaliste et un
technicien pour leur reportage réalisé à
l'issue d'une formation de deux semaines
dispensées par nos confrères de RFI il
remporte avec cette distinction quatre
semaines de formation à Paris Esther ce
n'est pas black samedi 25 ans et
lauréate journaliste elle est originaire
du Cameroun et Tian Rakoto Malala 26 ans
de Madagascar remporte lui la bourse du
technicien de reportage écoutez
je suis très émue je suis très heureuse
je suis comblée j'ai pas assez de mots
pour pouvoir exprimer ce que je ressens
à l'instant parce que c'est la
réalisation d'un rêve de petite fille
j'ai toujours rêvé de
postuler à cette bourse là bon en
grandissant j'ai toujours rêvé de faire
ce métier et puis quand l'occasion s'est
présentée pour moi de postuler à cette
bourse j'ai pas hésité en plus que
j'étais encouragée par les amis par des
collègues et tout et puis aujourd'hui
c'est
j'ai pas de Chevreuse pendant la période
covid nous avons maintenu bien sûr la
bourse cette façon de rendre hommage à
Ghislaine et Claude nous l'avons
maintenu en la faisant en distanciel et
nous avions ouvert les candidatures à
l'ensemble des pays d'Afrique
francophone 25 pays et pour la première
fois nous revenons sur le continent
africain et là pareil 24 pays
représentés dans les candidatures et 12
pays représentés dans les les stagiaires
qui qui ont suivi cette formation
pendant deux semaines et donc c'est un
mélange formidable de jeunes de
professionnels de journalisme de
techniciens qui échangent sur la réalité
de leur pays qui n'est absolument pas la
même selon qu'on vienne d'Afrique
centrale d'Afrique sahélienne d'Afrique
de l'Ouest
Paris-Dakar à vélo un jeune sénégalais a
quitté à la capitale française le 17
septembre pour rallier Dakar à vélo
objectif sensibilisé contre
l'immigration clandestine et le
changement climatique il est de retour
au Sénégal après 45 jours de périple
notre correspondant à limandao la
rencontrer sur la route de Dakar après
près de 7000 km et 45 jours à vélo Bamba
est arrivé au Sénégal ce lundi poursuit
sa route vers Dakar se spécialiste du
400 mètres et du 800 mètres n'est pas un
cycliste professionnel mais a tenu à
faire cette route à vélo en partant au
quotidien son parcours sur les réseaux
sociaux avec un message porteur sur
l'écologie mais également sur
l'immigration donc clandestine nous
l'avons rencontré à la sortie de guymey
à 150 km de Dakar écouter moi mon
message en fait c'est pas de dire aux
jeunes ne partez pas en Europe
c'est pas mon message parce que moi je
vis en Europe donc je sais ce que c'est
de vivre en Europe mon message c'est de
dire aux jeunes africains qui veulent
venir en Europe venez dans les
conditions légales d'abord et sur ces
conditions-là c'est beaucoup mieux quand
on arrive dans un pays qu'on connaît pas
pour s'adapter et le deuxième combat qui
concerne l'écologie et le développement
durable il y a que nous les jeunes qui
devons porter le combat pour aller en
avant aujourd'hui
tous les Africains sont concernés le
monde entier est concerné Bamba va
arriver à Dakar ce jeudi ils sont
nombreux sur les réseaux sociaux à
vouloir lui réserver un grand accueilli
une fois sur la capitale sénégalaise
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'Afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition Celia
carracena et merci à vous de nous suivre
et nous être fidèles l'info continue sur
France 24
[Musique]